cbs news chief washington correspondent
major garrett joins us now to talk about
president biden's no good very bad week
major garrett good morning to you
i asked this first question with a good
degree of humility because the answer
may be we just don't know but what do
you think at this juncture are the short
and medium and long-term implications
politically for president biden well two
things have happened to the president in
this week his
use of experience i'm the most
experienced i can handle i've seen these
things before i know how to manage them
that has been deeply damaged also his
competence which was reinforced by the
administration's early response to
vaccinations in their distribution in
the early days of covet 19 under his
watch both competence and experience
have been severely undermined don't take
my word for it i've talked to democrats
in washington on capitol hill they
believe those two things have happened
and once those cracks in that veneer are
there they're very hard to repair so
with a president who says i'm
experienced i've seen so many things
i've been to afghanistan so many times
and who didn't protect didn't see didn't
foresee didn't plan for this kind of
scenario when many people inside and
outside the administration were at least
warning it was possible well he's now
inherited a situation and the country
has to wrap its head around this tony
gail and anthony
right now for americans to leave
afghanistan and our afghan allies
the only way they can do that is with
the permission and at the suffrance of
the taliban wow so the president has yet
to acknowledge any errors of judgment or
any errors period when it comes to this
pull-out in afghanistan which seems to
be the only posture that politicians can
take these days but what do you make of
the messaging from the white house the
president does one thing over and over
and over i made a bold decision i
decided to leave afghanistan an american
president was going to make that move
i'm the one who made it fair enough it's
a tough decision
but as president you own every
consequence of every tough decision and
i've covered a lot of american
presidents unexpected and tragic things
happen and you have to be prepared on
the fly to deal with them but when you
circle a date on a calendar in a battle
space like afghanistan you own every
worst case scenario and if you don't
plan for them you will be doubly
condemned by history for circling that
date on the calendar and not planning
adequately for it i know let's talk
about that date major you know right now
it's august 31st how can you say you're
going to meet the deadline when you
don't know exactly how many people that
need to be evacuated this is the most
mysterious part of the white house
messaging currently i can only
understand a scenario which any american
president says we will stay until every
american who wants to leave is out
safely and our afghan allies who we've
identified and there's a huge blank
space in the white house preparation for
this i know because i've talked to many
people who work in the special immigrant
visa community and since april when the
president made this decision bold as it
was they warned the administration there
are thousands of afghans who work for us
who we've made a moral commitment to and
you've got to process them and you've
got to be prepared to process them
rapidly ramp that up do it now we've got
names we've got assistance we can help
you the administration ignored them for
weeks upon weeks upon weeks and now
everyone is desperate everyone is trying
to get out and the only way they can do
so is they get a thumbs up from the
taliban major the the president is going
to give remarks later today on the
evacuation uh efforts
why do you think the president has been
so defiant in this decision and what do
you think the long-term the long-term
impact is going to be on his presidency
well tony referred to that a minute ago
in modern american politics defiance
seems to be the coin of political realm
just say hey i did it i'm doing it it's
there and i'm not going to make any
apologies or accept any blame or
acknowledge even any mistakes
but this is a classic example where if
you will the audio doesn't match the
video yes what the administration is
saying publicly simply doesn't hold up
to any scrutiny even casual scrutiny on
the ground in afghanistan or as we just
mentioned in this emerging humanitarian
crisis in doha again where we are not
prepared we're not prepared with
bathrooms we're not prepared with food
we're not prepared with air conditioning
and people who have made it out of the
country who we are processing because
they made a commitment to us during 20
years of war can't even find a bathroom
get a meal or have some kind of relief
from scorching heat
all of that is an enormous stress on the
military and the state department
they're doing their best they can and
i'm not criticizing them for where we
are what i'm saying is this president
and his indifference to things he was
warned about put us where we are and
that's a fact yeah might have been the
right decision but it sure looks and
feels so bad yeah it's an ugly scene and
now two countries as you point out major
garrett thank you very much